c'est tout le chêne
michel bonsoir vous connaissez mia
croire massage c'est sympa vale est
tellement contente d'être sortie de la
base
alors kool shen l'autre moitié de ntm
depuis quatre ans un thème n'existe plus
chacun s'occupe de ses preuves joey
starr il s'occupe de bosses et vous de
format epub paul est aujourd'hui kool
shen arrive votre premier cd premier cd
solo qui s'appelle dernier round
vous répondez quoi quand on vous dit que
c'est un album de ntm sans joey starr je
me demande si c'est vraiment possible de
faire un bond theme sans joey starr
maintenant j'ai essayé de faire la
continuité de ce que j'avais fait
auparavant j'ai pas l'impression d'être
vraiment différent quand je sens un beau
mais il ya quelques touche plus
personnelle on va dire dans l'album ce
qui est un beau solo ouais c'est un
disque sans concession aussi sombre que
l'époque rien à voir avec ce qu'on
entend ce moment c'est vraiment hardcore
tu l'as dit ça ça ressemble un peu à
l'époque
enfin quand on ouvre un quotidien
aujourd'hui on se tape six poches sur la
guerre trois passes sur le fait que tout
le monde est dans la rue en france
[ __ ] de trois pages un peu plus de
bonne humeur vers la fin juin qu'il ya
un ou deux options qui sont un peu plus
en retrait mais déjà le titre dernier
round
comment ça se fait dernièrement vous
allez pas raccrocher les gants à 36 ans
quand non mais il ya un morceau
avec oxmo puccino dans l'album s'appelle
dernière ondée qui raconte plutôt qui
résume plutôt bien l'album et qui dit
qu'il vaut mieux essayer de faire les
choses à fond chaque jour comme si
c'était un peu le dernier c'est pas si
demain où la lumière va s'étendre dans
une cave où vous livrez pas mal c'est
l'âge sûrement moment c'est sûrement
plus difficile de ce livre et quand on
nage pas 24 25 ans et qu'on est en
pleine période d'affirmations surtout
quand on fait du rap us pièce d'armure
qui était un peu obligé d'avoir on va
dire et avec les membres
ouais alors il ya premier single
s'appelle qui suis-je donc je suis une
espèce d'autoportraits où vous dites oui
que la vérité sur vous avec beaucoup de
franchise
j'essaye way à ses premiers albums solo
donc je trouve est nécessaire d'arriver
avec un morceau qui s'appelle ski sujet
qui me définit pas ce qu'on m'a toujours
défini à l'intérieur d'un groupe donc
c'était l'occasion de 1/2 vrai moi
l'enchère l'époque sur le début du vingt
et unième siècle qui assez mal barrés et
c'est vrai vous dit quand on voit le
documentaire de choix qui à la télé les
juifs d'un côté les musulmans de l'autre
oui je reconnais plus la banlieue c'est
à dire que quand vous étiez plus jeune y
avait passé ce communautarisme la dent
j'ai l'impression qu'on a tous grandi
dans la même merde et que et qui avait
passé séparation là aujourd'hui
bon après ça reste encore un reportage
et un cas précis mais on on sent qu'ils
en espèces de communautariste qui se
forment kaki pas bon et qu'un opus
relayée par les médias et c'est donc
donc voilà c'est j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu mal barré
et pas qu'en france terre vous croyez
plus trop aux lendemains qui chantent
inquira pas à vraiment on écrivait le
monde de demain quoi qu'il advienne nous
appartient et il ya 15 ans aujourd'hui
si plus tôt c'est mal barré
ouais vous êtes dans cet état là aussi
vous anthony zeddam soucieux sur
l'avenir du monde nos confrères avec
votre belle gueule vous dites que tout
ira toujours bien
les enfants attirés ouais c'est vrai
donc comme j'ai des enfants et c'est
qu'ils m'ont je suis très soucieux de
l'avenir du monde j'y pense tous les
jours
moi maintenant ça y est c'est un peu
c'est un peu s'est déjà engagé quoi un
aidant 20 pis ça va être dur il ya
beaucoup de gens qui s'ouvre jeudi
l'avenir de la planète et on ne remercie
de tarés web à tata reçues les gars
qu'on réécrire new york brûle-t-il la
main moi je les ai vu l'émission je te
dis franchement à la fin de l'émission
tu rigole moins
même si tu rigoles est pas au début ce
déjà là quand centre en plus consternant
donc avec les yeux ouverts mais il ya
des gens qui font des choses aussi super
positive et aussi la musique c'est aussi
fait pour danser et à mener voilà moi
c'est parce que j'ai voulu faire quand
j'écris alors très personnelle également
le morceau consacrer à votre ancienne
compagne qui s'est tué dans un accident
de voiture s'appelle un ange dans le
ciel